welcome back
in the last section we talked about
validation and we saw some drawbacks
with that method now we're going to talk
about k-fold cross-validation which will
solve some of these problems
this is actually a very important
technique that we're going to use
throughout the course in various
sections and also something that we use
in our work all the time
so it's really important to to
understand careful cross-validation it's
very very it's used for a lot of methods
it's extremely
flexible and powerful powerful technique
for estimating prediction error and to
get an idea of model complexity
so
what's the idea of k-4 cross-validation
well it's really in the name it's it's
validation as we've seen but done
uh sort of like a k-k-part play it's
done k times
with each part
getting to play the role of of the
validation set and the other k minus one
parts
um playing the role of the training set
which i say here but let me go to the
picture here
and i'll sort of point the picture as i
say it so here we're doing five-fold
cross-validation
as we'll talk about in more detail but
the best choices for k number of folds
is usually about five or ten
okay so
and i'll explain we'll talk about that
in a few minutes about why those are
good choices but let's fix here k equals
five
so i've taken the data set i've divided
it random
the samples into five parts again of
size about the same if
um the rate box looks a bit bigger right
okay that's my uh my lack of uh
drawing ability but anyway this is
supposed to be the same that's trying to
squish the word validation in so the
boxes are supposed to people the same
size and observation number of
observations but the for in this case
the first parts the validation set the
other for the training parts so what
we're going to do what cross validation
does
it forms this
this uh this these five parts we're
going to train the model on the four
training parts put together as one big
block
take the fitted model and then
predict on the validation part and
record the error and then that's that's
phase one phase two we're gonna the the
validation start will be
part two
this this block all the other four parts
will be the training set
we fit the model to the training set and
then apply it to this validation part
and in the third stage this is the
validation piece etc so we have sort of
we have we have five stages where each
in each stage one part gets to play the
role of validation set the other four
parts of the training set
we take all the all the prediction
errors from all five parts we add them
together and that gives us what's called
the cross validation error
so
now in algebra i'll basically give you
the details of what i said in words
so we'll let the k parts
be of the data be c1 through ck
so these are the observations that are
in each of the five parts remember k was
five in our example
and we'll try to make the number of
observations about the same in every
part of course if n is not a multiple of
k or 5 we can't do that exactly but
we'll do it approximately
so we'll let
n sub k be the number of observations in
the kth part
so here's the cross validation error
rate
basically
this is the mean square error we get by
applying
uh the
the
we fit to the
k minus 1 parts that don't involve
part number k that gives us our fit y i
hat
uh for observation i it's four fifths of
the data in this case right and then we
add up the error this is the mean square
error that we obtain now on the
validation part using that model
so it's this is for the k part and now
we do this for all five parts in turn
the five acts of the play and now we get
the cross validation error rate
okay
and a special case of this is leave one
l cross validation where the number of
folds is the same as the number of
observations so that means
in this picture that actually would be
uh
one box per observation
and in level out cross validation each
observation by itself gets to play the
role of the validation set the the other
n minus one of the training set
okay
now actually level cross validation is
is has a there's a nice special case of
that it it represents a nice special
case in the sense that this
cross-validation can be done without
actually having to refit the model at
all
so in we've went out cross-validation
uh at least for a least squares model or
or a polynomial model
if the
the cross validation
level cross foundation has the following
form
so the the y i hat is now just to fit on
the full data set
h i
is the
um
diagonal of the hat matrix so have a
look in the book for details but the hat
matrix is the
projection matrix that projects y onto
the column space of x to give you the
fit this is something that can get
computed easily when you fit your least
squares model so go ahead trevor yeah
yeah it's we don't
we haven't emphasized it but it's
available it's one of the things that's
available when you fit your least
squares model so the overall point of
this is that you to do a level cross
foundation for these particular models
you don't actually have to leave
anything out you can do the fit on the
overall data set and then extract the
information you need to get the cross
validation sum of squares and it's
interesting because the hi tells you how
much influence an observation has on its
own fit it's a number between 0 and 1.
and so if an observation is very
influential on its own fit
you can see it punishes the residual
because it divides by a number that's
small and it inflates the residual so it
sort of does the right thing here
okay so um
but
a better choice although leaving all
cross-validation does have this nice
computational formula for for most of
the methods we talk about in this book
in most statistical learning methods
it's better to choose k to be five or
ten rather than have it have leave on
all cross validation
um and why is that well
um
one problem with level and i'll cross
validation is each of the training sets
look very much like the other ones right
they only differ by one observation
so when you take the average
cross validation is is uh you take the
average of errors
um over the n folds and
in level cross validation the end flows
look very similar to each other because
the training sets are almost the same
they're only different by one
observation so as a result that average
has a high variance because the
ingredients are highly correlated
so
that's the main reason why
it's it's thought and we also agree that
a better choice for for k and cross
validation is 5 or ten
on the other hand the the leave one out
cross validation is actually trying to
estimate the error rate for the training
sample of almost the same size as what
you have
so it's got low bias but as rob said
high variance so actually
picking k is a is also a bias variance
trade of for prediction area and as rob
said k equals 5 or 10 tend to be a good
choice
so the next slide we've got a comparison
of level cross validation
uh and tenfold cv for the the auto data
remember before we saw with two-fold
validation well we started with
just validation into two parts we got a
lot of variability between the ten the
when we change the sample that we the
half sample that we took
now let's see what happens we'll leave
it all cross validation we get a curve
that's
again got the minimum around the same
place as we saw before
and then it's pretty flat after that
a 10-fold cross-validation now again
it's it's also showing the minimum
around two but it's uh there's not the
we're seeing here is the
tenfold cross validation as we as we uh
take
different partitions into ten parts of
the data and we see there's not much
variability they're pretty consistent
in contrast to the uh when we divide
into two parts we've got much more
variability
and those get averaged as well those
curves in the right exactly so yeah
right so they're averaged together
which we saw here they're averaged
together to give us the overall estimate
of cross-validation
which the overall cross-validation curve
will be will look very much like this
with its minimum around
two
okay
this is um
this is figure 5.6 from the textbook and
this is the
simulated data example which was figured
from figure 2.9 of the book
just recall that this is smoothing
splines in three different situations
in this case the true curve two error
curve is the blue curve
and again these three different
functions that we're examining
this is mean square error for simulated
data a true error curve how do we get
that rob
well simulated data so we just uh oh so
we can get a we can get a very big test
set exactly and estimate the error
exactly level cross validation is the
the black
broken line
and the orange curve is 10 full cross
validation
so we can see what do we see well here
we see that
test error curve is a little higher than
the
10 fold and leave one out cross
validation
the minimum's
fairly close but
the minimum of cross-validation is
around eight whereas the true curve is
minimized around six
in this case uh the two cross validation
methods are doing a a better job of
approximating the test error curve and
have the minimum well the minimums again
they're fairly close not exactly
on this on the mark blocker is minimized
around six
and the the true error curve is
minimized around
x maybe three although those those error
curves are fairly flat
so there's obviously a high variance in
in where the minimum should be
right it doesn't really matter
you know that's right it's not going to
matter much if you choose a model with
flexibility 2 or maybe even 10 here
because the error is pretty flat in that
region
and then the third example the the two
cross validation curves do a quite a
good job of approximating the test error
curve and the minimum is around 10 in
each case
okay
so actually i said this already but i'll
say it again that one issue with one
issue with cross validation is that
since the training set is not as big as
the original training set
the essence of prediction will be
will be biased up a little bit because
we have less data we're working with
working with
and
i also said and i'll say again that
leave one out cross validation
has
smaller bias in this sense because the
training set is almost the same size as
the original set but the other hand it's
got a higher variance because the
training sets that it's using
are almost the same as the original set
they only differ by one observation
so k k equals five or ten fold is a good
compromise for this buy interference
trade-off
okay so in the we talked about
cross-validation for a quantitative
response and we use mean square error
for classification problems that is
exactly the same the only thing it
changes is is a measure of error of
course no longer use square but a
misclassification error otherwise cross
validation process is exactly the same
divide the data up into k parts
we train on k minus one parts
we record the error on the kth part and
we add things up together to get the
overall cross validation error it looks
like a weighted average in that formula
there's n k over n
well do you want to explain that because
each of the folds might not be exactly
the same size
so we we actually
compute a weight which is proportional
to this which is the relative size of
the of the fold and then use a weighted
average right and if we are lucky that
the k divides the n divides by k exactly
then that weight will just be one
one over k right
um one other thing to add which
is that since this cross validation
error is just an average
the standard error of that average
also gives us a standard error of the
cross-validation estimate so we take the
error rates from each of the folds their
average is the cross-validation error
rate
their standard error is the standard
the standard deviation of the
cross-validation estimate so here's the
formula for that so this is a useful
this is a useful quantity
and when we draw cv curves we should
always put a standard error band around
the curve to get any of the variability
so in these previous pictures we should
have had a standard error band around
the curves to give us an idea of how how
variable they are
i say here it's useful but not quite
valid
why is that
dr hastie
well i wonder why well the thing is we
we compute in the standard errors if
these were independent observations but
they're not strictly independent arab
sub k
overlaps with error sub
j because they share some training
samples
so there's some correlation between them
but we use this anyway we use and it's
actually quite a good estimate and
people have shown this mathematically
again the important point being that is
that the cross validation separates the
training part of the data from the
validation part when we talk about the
bootstrap method the next part of this
this section we'll see that that's not
the case and that's going to cause a
problem so cross-validation explicitly
separates the training set from the
validation set in order to get a good
idea of test error
okay so
this again i just i want to
re-emphasize that cross-validation is a
very important technique to understand
um both for for quantitative response
and cross-validation and um
classification